RICHARD PRUM: People have been interested in the colors of dinosaurs
for as long as they've known that the fossils existed.
They interpreted the colors of dinosaurs based on living reptiles--
scaly
and usually
dark browns or muted greens. In the
late nineties, people began to discover
feathered dinosaurs-- dinos with dino-fuzz.
At that point it became interesting to know
what that-- how those feathers could have influenced
the appearance of them.
JAKOB VINTHER: How we found out is that--
fossil feathers, they preserve the melanin--
that is the pigment that gives the color to the feather.
So the way that that I got the idea that we
could potentially use this to put colors on dinosaurs
came from a very odd angle,
'cause I was actually looking at fossil squids.
And we find fossil squids
that have the ink cells preserved,
and quite interestingly, when you look at this
fossilized
ink, you can actually see that
it preserves the pigments.
And that made me think that
we should be able to find
this pigment, which is melanin, in other
kinds of fossils,
such as, for example, feathers.
PRUM: Melanin is created by pigment cells
which package them in little organelles called
melanosomes. These melanosomes are
tiny little packages, they come
in oblong or rounded
shapes.
VINTHER: We have a locality in Denmark that is about fifty five million years old
where we find fossilized birds
with feathers. So when I took this fossil under a scanning electro-microscope,
and started zooming in on the fossil feathers,
I was just met by this ocean of little
sausage-shaped structures,
and that confirmed my expectations that melanin
is very abundant
in fossils, and also
it means that we can
use this sort of information to put colors on dinosaurs.
PRUM: What we were able to do
was compare the shape
and size and density
of the melanosomes in these fossil feathers
to the feathers of living birds,
and thereby
interpret or predict the color
of these fossil feathers when the animal
was alive.
This has allowed us to create the first
description
of the plumage color
of an extinct dinosaur in history.
DEREK BRIGGS: The dinosaur is an animal called Anchiornis
and it's about the size of a chicken.
And it has a rather spectacular plumage, including
a red color on
the crest.
And
spotting and bracketing
of black and white and grey colors on the rest of the plumage.
VINTHER: What Ricky said when he first saw this
thing and we started realizing what kind of
color patterns it had, he said, it looks like a
spangled hen bird.
If you see this Anchiornis, as it's called,
and just have a quick look at it, and look away, I think most people would say that it
looks like chicken.
BRIGGS: This fossil is from
the latest Jurassic of Liaoning province in China.
So these Chinese examples are extraordinary
in that many of them do have an outline of
the feathers of most extinct birds and these
early dinosaurs.
VINTHER: So the interesting prospect of this is that
we can see that melanin is
in all these fossil feathers.
It's the rule rather than the exception.
PRUM: The future
in dinosaur paleontology and the paleontology of birds
and mammals
will be that we
we will probably be able to reconstruct in
some
detail
the color
that they had in life.
This is like writing
the first field guide page in
the field guide to the dinosaurs.
And it's one of the most exciting
moments of science I've ever had.